tesoro com'è andata a scuola tutto bene
racconta racconta cosa Aspetta simpatia
pescheria
Sì ti sto ascoltando amore No vabbè
guarda c'è questo cagnolino che parla
troppo simpatico Cioè non è che parla
lui gli mettono le voci sopra hai capito
Senti ma io ti devo chiedere una cosa
quando io vedo le ricette no le video
ricette le metto nei salvati Ma dove
sono questi salvati Ma guarda questa che
dice questo lavoro e rubare ora le
commento Vergognati ladra è una parodia
comunque Facebook io non lo uso più Eh
no è pieno di come si chiamano i boomers
no per carità Hai visto che bella la
vittoria dei ferragnez Ma dovresti
saperlo Scusa Vuoi vedere un film Sì sì
Mettilo Mettilo Senti ma che cos'è uno
Ship Ah sì sì scusa guardiamo il film
guardiamo se hai ragione hai ragione No
ma questi podcast no come funzionano
Cioè li possono fare proprio a tutti li
potrei fare anche io io in avrai di cose
da raccontare uh uh Certo che questi
Social sono proprio una figata Ci
fossero stati i miei tempi Eh magari
facevo la la tiktoker e non l'impiegata
Aspetta che c'è la Ferri in diretta
Metti in pausa che voglio vederla